في الصين زحام في عطله راس السنه القمريه
ومخوف من موجه تفش جديده لفيروس كورونا
يبددها مسؤولون الصينيون كبير خبراء
الاوبئه في المركز الصيني لمكافحه الامراض
والوقايه منها كان اخر المطمئنين في هذا
الشان دون التهويل من تداعيات حركه التنقل
الضخمه الجاريه في البلاد
حركه التنقل الضخمه خلال فتره عطله السنه
القمريه الجديده يحتمل ان تعمل على انتشار
الوباء ما يفاقم العدوى في بعض المناطق
ولكن ليس من المرجح حدوث موجه جديده 19
على المدى القريب
حصانه المناعه الجماعيه من فيروس كورونا
تحول سكان الصين من مواجهه موجه تفشل
ثانيه فوفقا للمركز الصيني لمكافحه
الامراض اصيب نحو 80% من المواطنين لكنها
حصانه مؤقته قد تستمر لمده ثلاثه اشهر
وفي ما يتوافد الصينيون على محطه السكك
الحديديه والمطارات للتوجه الى مناطق
بمناسبه عطله راس السنه القمريه حضر
الرئيس شيمبيغ من عدم جاهزيه المناطق
الريفيه للتعامل مع تطورات الفايروس لابد
من بذل المزيد من الجهود لتحسين رعايه
الطبيه للفئات المعرضه للاصابه بالفيروس
في المناطق الريفيه ومعالجه نواقص في
الوقايه من الاوبئه في هذه المناطق
اما البيانات الرسميه الاخيره فاشارت الى
وفات نحو ستين الف مواطن صيني بسبب كورونا
على مدار شهر حتى الثاني عشر من يناير
الجاري الامر الذي يضع الوضع الصحي في
الصين تحت مجهر الترقب خاصه بعد التخلي عن
سياسه صفر كوفد السارمه علي السمان
العربيه